DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome, everyone!
It is June 28th, 2022
and we are here in ActInfLab GuestStream
number 24.1.
Today we're here with Professor
Stephen Grossberg
and the agenda will be as follows.
First,
Ali will provide a short introduction.
We will then play a 45 minute
prerecorded video followed by a Q&A.
So thanks, everyone, for joining.
And Professor Grossberg,
really appreciate joining.
And I'll pass to Ali
for the introduction.
ALI RAHMJOO: Hello and welcome!
I'm Ali. I'm an independent researcher
from Iran.
I'm very happy and excited to be here
and be able to speak with
Professor Grossberg today.
So I'd like to thank Professor Grossberg
for joining us.
Stephen Grossberg is the Wang Professor
of Cognitive and Neural Systems
and a professor emeritus of mathematics
in the statistics, psychological
and brain sciences and biomedical
engineering at Boston University.
For more than 50 years,
he has led pioneering research
in discovering and developing
neural design principles
for autonomous adaptive intelligence
based on biological and machine learning.
His neural network models
have been applied to many large scale
problems in engineering and technology,
including the design of increasingly
autonomous
adaptive algorithms and mobile agents.
In fact,
this is what Karl Friston says about him.
Whenever you claim to be the first to do
this or that in artificial intelligence,
it is customary and correct to add,
with the exception of Stephen Grossberg.
Quite simply, Stephen is a living giant
and foundational architect of the field.
Professor
Grossberg is the recipient of the 2015
Norman Anderson Lifetime Achievement
Award of the Society
of Experimental Psychologists, the 2017
Frank Rosenblatt Award of the Tripoli
Computational Intelligence Society
and the 2019
Donald Wahab Award of the International
Neural Network Society.
His latest book, "Conscious Mind, Resonant
Brain," as a culmination of his decades
long research written in a rather
non-technical and conversational style,
is published in 2021
by Oxford University Press
and is the winner of the Association
of American Publishers in 2022
Prose Award for the Best
Book of the Year in Neuroscience.
Now I'll pass it to Professor Grossberg
and then we'll continue
with the 45 minute prerecorded lecture.
FRIEDMAN: If you'd like to say hi...
otherwise, I'll begin the video.
GROSSBERG: (I just saw my face frozen on the screen!)
Well, I'm delighted to be here, and
I hope you
find some
points of interest in the lecture.
And I'll look forward to the Q&A.
Ali has prepared a series of questions
that I've thought about
and have some prepared, sketched answers.
And then after that, if you're
still interested, I'm happy to do.
Live Q&A about anything related
to the topics of the day.
FRIEDMAN: OK! - On to the main course.
I will play the video now.
(And you won't hear anything on the live
stream.
I'll crop it,
and the audio will be coming through
fine now.)
GROSSBERG (via video): Hello!
I'm delighted to be able
to speak to you today
about a topic concerning
artificial intelligence,
which, as you know,
is very much in the news these days.
And I'll be contrasting
two very different approaches
to artificial intelligence.
But to do that, I need to pull up
my PowerPoint slide cards
and share them with you
and let me maximize them
and minimize my space.
So my topic today
is explainable and reliable. A.I.
Comparing deep learning with adaptive
resonance.
This lecture is based
on the following article from this year,
which is both open access
and on my web page.
The articles summarizes
core problems of deep learning,
such as its untrustworthiness.
Because it's unexplainable
and it's unreliable
because it experiences
catastrophic forgetting.
The article explains
how adaptive resonance overcomes
these problem and indeed overcomes
17 problems of deep learning
and outlines
a blueprint for achieving autonomous
adaptive intel diligence.
The article is part of a frontiers
in robotics special issue
about explainable A.I.,
whose editors wrote and I quote,
though deep learning
is the main pillar of current A.I.
techniques and is ubiquitous in
basic science in real world applications.
It is also flagged by AI researchers
for its black box problem.
It is easy to fool us
and it also cannot explain
how it makes a prediction or decision.
In other words,
deep learning is not trustworthy.
No life or death decision,
such as a medical or financial decision,
can confidently be made
based upon a deep learning prediction.
Deep learning is in the back propagation
algorithm for learning
how to predict out the factors
in response to win protect is
that propagation was based on perceptron
learning principles
that Frank Rosenblatt's
started to introduce in the 1950s.
It has a complicated history,
which Juergen Schmidthuber
beautifully refuted in an article
from this year.
Major contributors include Shinichi
Amari for Bros and David Parker.
Perhaps one would say that
it reached its modern form with simulated
applications in Paul's 1974 paper
before being popularized 12 years later
by Rummel, Hart, Hinton and Williams
is a schematic of a back propagation
circuit with printed word
from a survey article by Gail
Carpenter of Neural Network Models.
Any information flows, feedforward
from an input stage to an output stage.
Learning
is supervised by an external teacher
who on each trial
defines a target or desired output.
The teaching signal is the error
or mismatch between the actual
and the target outputs.
The teaching signal in level
three of adaptive weights
and level left to have no network pathway
whereby to reach from F3
to EC2 within the algorithm.
So the algorithm uses an artifice
called way transport,
which physically lifts the weights
from here and moves them there
so that they can be used to control
learning.
Well,
this is clearly a non-local operation
as well as being clearly
non-biological.
Back propagation learns
through slow learning, which means that
the adaptive weights change
just a little to reduce error
on each learning trial.
That requires many trials,
that is to say, many repetitions
of the whole database to learn possibly
hundreds or thousands of trials.
This is to be contrasted with fast
learning
where adaptive weights zero error signals
on each trial, just as we can learn
a phase that we see just once
and remember it for a long time.
If back prop try to use fast
learning would become
wildly unstable.
Catastrophic
forgetting also occurs in back prop
so that during any learning trial,
an untreated active
part of its learning memory
can unexpectedly collapse.
So deep learning, which is based on back
propagation, is thus neither reliable
nor trustworthy.
But why is this?
One reason is that all inputs a process
by a shared set of learned weights,
the algorithm cannot selectively buffer
learned weights
that are still predictably useful.
In particular,
there's no attention mechanism.
This problem occurs in any learning
algorithm whose shared weight updates
follow the gradient of the error
in response
to the current batch of data points
while ignoring past actions.
There have been
multiple efforts to fix back propagation.
One is to selectively slow learning
on the weights, important for learning
by optimizing parameters
using the Bayes rule,
as Kirkpatrick Atoll
suggested a few years ago.
But that assumes and omniscient observer
who can discover and alter
the important weights
as well as non-local computation
such as the Bayesian computation.
The same problem occurs
with evolutionary algorithms
and diffusion based neuromodulation
and other approaches
to try to fix spectra from
these efforts to overcome catastrophic
forgetting
created additional conceptual
and computational problems.
I view them as adding epicycles
to ameliorate
a fundamental flaw in the model,
which to me is reminiscent of adding
Epicycles to correct problems in the
Ptolemaic model of the solar system.
As we all know, the Copernican model
that we now
accept didn't require epicycles.
Perhaps this is why Geoffrey Hinton,
who played a key role in developing
both back prop and deep learning,
said in an Axios interview
a few years ago that, quote,
he's "deeply
suspicious of back propagation.
I don't think it's how the brain works.
We clearly don't need
all the labeled data.
My view is throw it all away
and start over."
I would claim we don't have to start over
because these problems were solved
in the 1970s and 1980s
in particular in the first issue
of the journal Neural Networks in 1988.
I had an article that listed
17 Problems of Back
Propagation that are overcome
by adaptive resonance.
And here they are
with regard to not needing to label data.
I noted in the third item here
that self-organized, unsupervised,
unsupervised learning
frees us from needing labels all the time
as to slow learning.
I noted that in art
you can have fast or slow learning.
Indeed.
Or can learn to classify
an entire database
using fast learning on a single learning
trial, says Gale Carpenter.
And I showed in the 1980s.
Rover Auto overcomes
all 17 problems of back propagation
without ex bicycles.
Furthermore,
all the
core AI predictions have been supported
by subsequent psychological
and neurobiological data.
Indeed, art is the principle,
biological and technological theory.
Unlike back prop and deep learning,
which are just AI algorithms,
Art has explained data from hundreds
of experiments, and it's made scores
of predictions that have subsequently
received experimental support.
But why has it been so successful?
There are a number of reasons,
but one of them is
that art can be derived from its thought
experiment about a universal problem
an error correction that I published
40 years ago in Psychological Review.
The thought experiment asks the question,
How can a coding error be corrected
if no individual cell knows
that one has occurred?
Let me quote from my paper
The importance of this issue
becomes clear
when we realize that erroneous cues
can accidentally be incorporated
into a code
when our interactions
with the environment is both
and will only become evident
when our environmental expectations
become more demanding.
And even if our code perfectly matched
a given environment,
we would certainly make errors.
As the environment itself fluctuates.
So I was talking about
autonomous local learning
in a changing world,
a purely logical inquiry into error
correction
is translated
at every step of the thought
experiment into processes.
Learning autonomously in real time
with only locally computed quantities.
Moreover, the thought experiment uses
familiar environmental facts
about how we learn as its hypotheses
and short circuits naturally emerge
where these facts are familiar
because they are you.
They are ubiquitous
environmental constraints
on the evolution of our brains.
And since we're living with them
all the time,
they become familiar
because of this.
Universally,
earth circuits made us in some form
be embodied in all future
truly autonomous.
Adaptive, intelligent devices
with a biological
or artificial,
or it has probably for this reason
already been used in many large scale
engineering
and technological applications.
In fact,
almost immediately after
it was introduced,
it began being used
because it succeeded in benchmark studies
against machine learning, back
propagation, statistical methods,
genetic algorithms
either getting much better accuracy
or much faster training, speed or both.
It's also used in applications
where other algorithms totally fail,
such as the Boeing Company's port
design, reuse and inventory
compression application.
That's just one of many large scale
applications in engineering and
technology, some of which can be found
on our Tech Live Web page at B.U.
dot edu.
The Boeing parts design
retrieval system in particular
was used to help design the Boeing 777.
And to do that, you needed fast
learning and stable memory to learn
and search a huge and continually
growing non stationary parts inventory.
At the time of this application.
There are already 16 million, 1
million dimensional vectors
that were used
to describe each of the parts
and you have to be able
to quickly search the inventory
if you want to find a part
to use in a new plane,
especially if your new design
might have a part in the inventory
that was similar to it.
Finding it and slightly modifying design
could save millions of
dollars in fabrication costs.
Satellite Remote
sensing is another large scale
application that art was used
for very soon, and Gail Carpenter
and a colleagues took the lead here
for example,
using a very small number of pixels
of ground truth of 17 vegetation classes.
They used art to automatically complete
these maps
using remote sensing data.
Or did it in a day rapidly
and automatically,
it gave a confidence map for each pixel
and the pixels with 30 meters
in scale,
which was small enough to see roads.
This contrasted with an AI expert system
which took a whole year to do with
and it had to derive at ad hoc rules
from experts.
You had to correct up upwards
of a quarter of a million site labels.
And even so, the pixel size
was an order of magnitude larger.
Gail went on
with her colleagues to study
information, fusion and remote sensing.
Let's say you have multiple observers.
Each of them may be using different
labels.
The labels may also be incomplete
or missing or even incorrect.
And the task was to derive
consistent knowledge
from potentially inconsistent data
to automatically learn
and stably store one too many mappings.
And along the way, Gail and a colleague
showed how to self-organize
a hierarchy of cognitive rules,
including confidence measures
between these different levels
of the hierarchy.
There's been continual work on art.
Some more recent work was summarized
in a special issue of neural networks
just in in December 2019
that was edited by Donald Bunch,
who started the special issue
with a general overview
of neural network models
that I and my colleagues developed,
and then went on in a long
and detailed article
with several collaborators
to provide a survey of adaptive
resonance theory neural network models
for engineering applications
to the present time,
so that propagation and deep learning
are a feedforward adaptive filter.
But art is more than that.
In fact, art is explainable
self-organizing production system
in a non stationary world.
What do these words mean?
Or self-organizing.
Because they can autonomously carry out
arbitrary combinations of unsupervised
or super sized
learning trials with the world
as its only teacher.
It's a production system
because it uses hypothesis testing
to discover and learn rules
by a top down matching process
that focuses attention
on critical feature patterns.
These are the patterns
that predict behavioral success
while suppressing irrelevant features,
or it's
explainable using both its activities
or short term memory.
As STM traces and its adaptive
way to a long term memory, LTM traces,
activation dynamics, learning dynamics,
observing the STM traces
in a critical feature pattern.
Explain in what recognition
categories will learn to code
and what features
predict goal oriented actions
and particularly the long term memory
traces in the fuzzy art map algorithm
translate into explicit fuzzy
if then rules that code.
What combat actions of critical features
in what numerical ranges
effectively control predictions
thereby illustrating one of many examples
where neural networks can learn
rule based
behaviors.
Art includes a bottom up adaptive filter,
a feedforward neural network,
as I've observed already,
but that's supplemented by top down
learned expectations
and two types of recurrent
inhibitory feedback interactions
that help to choose the recognition
categories and the critical features.
Notably, top down expectations
use what Joe Carpenter
and I call the art matching rule to learn
how to focus attention
on critical features
that control predictive success.
The art matching rule is another way
of talking
computationally
about the process of object attention
how we pay attention
to salient objects in the world,
and we show how it stabilizes learning
and thereby avoids catastrophic
forgetting.
Remarkably, and this has been
supported by many data,
the art matching role can be realized
by a top down
modulatory on center or surround network.
Where? What does this mean?
Well, let's say we have bottom up
inputs from external features
to feature selective cells
that get stored in short term memory.
Let's say
we activate a recognition category
which has previously been learned
and tries to read out
its learned excitatory prototype.
But it can't fully do so
because it also reads out
an inhibitory of surround
that's broader than the prototype.
So this is approximately one excitatory
against once inhibitory.
It can only give you
one modulatory on center.
But if you have both bottom up inputs
and the top down
expectation simultaneously active,
then within the bounds of the prototype.
If you also have a bottom up feature,
you have two excitatory
against one inhibitory
and those features can be
selected,
gained, amplified and synchronized.
To start focusing attention
on this critical feature pattern.
Well, outlier features
the ones that aren't within the prototype
only have one excitation
against one inhibition or suppressed.
And in
1999, I was able to begin to understand
how lamina cortical circuits
carry out object attention.
In particular, layer
six of a higher cortical area
can activate layer
six of a lower cortical area,
either directly or via a five,
and then it can fold up the layer
for to modulate in, on center
and to inhibit and of surround.
So attention x by a top down
modulatory on center of surround network
by a folded feedback
within lamina neocortex.
And this is one example of the paradigm
of lamina computing that I introduced,
which ask Why are all neocortical
circuits organized in layers?
And how do laminar circuits
give rise to all kinds
of biological intelligence?
Adaptive resonance sets
is the story
because attended feature clusters
react elevate their bottom up pathways,
activated categories
reactivate their top down
pathways closing in excitatory
feedback loop
between features and categories,
giving rise to a feature category
resonance
that synchronizes, amplifies
and prolongs system response
between the attended critical features
and the category to which they are bound.
And it's this resonance
that triggers fast learning
in the bottom up and top down.
Adaptive waits,
which is why I have called
this theory adaptive resonance theory.
Moreover,
I've done a lot of work
since then, showing that all
conscious states or resonant states
and these feature category
resonances are one example of that,
one that supports conscious
recognition of visual objects and scenes.
There's a lot of data support
for our predictions.
It's well known that attention
does happen on center of surround
a circuit behind it, and that attention
can facilitate matched bottom up signals.
Many other data as well.
So now we can say more about
why art is explainable or trustworthy
in short term memory.
It's because the critical feature
patterns
determine the attentional focus
that controls information processing.
And you can just read off what
those features are in long term memory.
Again, it's the critical feature patterns
that determine the adaptive way
to learn by the bottom up adaptive filter
and the top down learned expectation.
So, you know
also what these weights are encoding
less reliable and
avoids catastrophic
forgetting because outlier features
that are not in the critical feature
pattern is suppressed
so that only the predictive features
are processed and coded.
Well, it's a production system
because it carries out
a kind of hypothesis testing.
And this is nicely illustrated
in the simplest art model called
or one that Gale Comparator
and I published in 1987
or at one has an attentional system
that does all the category learning
and the expectation learning
and the paying attention
that interacts with an orienting system
which is activated
when there are big enough matches
in the attentional system and thereby
drives a reset and search for novel.
Look at a match in categories.
Here's a schematic of the yard
hypothesis testing and learning cycle.
So let's say you
have a bottom up
feature pattern coming in.
There may be many,
many active bottom of features,
but I'll draw
just one arrow here for simplicity.
But that vector of input features
can activate
a distributed pattern of feature detector
cells.
Some may be very active, some
not so active, some not active at all.
And as this is happening,
each of these active
pathways is trying
to turn on the orienting system.
So there might be quite a few inputs
converging here, but as the features
are activated, each of them tries
to inhibit the orienting system
and there is many features
as there are inputs.
So this excitation
and addition of balance,
keeping the orienting system quiet
as the feature padding goes,
the adaptive filter
and chooses a category.
That category reads out of learned
top down expectation
that obeys the art matching rule,
which can suppress a mismatch features,
thereby reducing the amount of inhibition
on the orienting system
and raising the question
when you have too little inhibition
and too much excitation.
How big a mismatch
will activate the orienting system
and cause reset and that
ratio is determined
by what's called vigilance,
which I'll say more about soon.
But if you don't have enough inhibition,
then the orienting system gets activated.
It equally activates
all the cells in the category layer
because it doesn't know
which cell may be active or not.
So it causes and novelty
sensitive, nonspecific bursts
of arousal, novel events or browsing,
thereby selectively
shutting off the active category,
eliminating its top down expectation,
and unmasking the original feature added,
which can again
go through the adaptive filter.
However, now this
previously this confirmed category
remains off
and the category level is we normalize
sort response to the same input bad
and with the new category
and you go through this cycle
of resonance and reset
until you get a good enough match
to either learn a new category
or select a previously learned category.
And it's a theorem that as categories
are learned through
this matching process, search
automatically
disengages
leading to direct access without search
to the globally best matching category.
Explaining, for example, how
we can quickly recognize familiar objects
like your mother's face.
Even if, as we get older, we store
enormous numbers of additional memories
so you don't have to search
your whole repertoire.
When you see Mom, you get direct
access and quickly say, Hi, Mom.
There's a lot of support
for the hypothesis testing cycle.
One source of support is from event
related potentials,
also called human scalp potentials,
which shows correlated sequences
of three different
evoked potentials
during oddball learning tasks.
An experiment that John Paul Bank
and I reported in the eighties
where you'll get a p120 for a mismatch
and then 200 for the arousal activated
by the ordering system
and a p300 for the short term memory
reset of the category layer, thereby
supporting the processing
stages of the search cycle.
There was also physiological data
from a temporal cortex
where categories are learned early on
from the lab of Bob Desdemona,
who showed an active matching process
that's reset between trials during
this kind of event.
There's also classical data
about hippocampal mismatch dynamics.
It's known that novelty potentials
subside
as learning proceeds
from numerous experiments.
This is as the orienting
system is disengaged,
and there's more recent data
using multiple
electrode studies
from the lab of Cheryl Miller,
from pre-frontal cortex and simultaneous
recordings in active campus.
And they show this rapid object
associative learning
may occur in prefrontal cortex,
which is a projection
of inferred temporal cortex,
one of the stages of category learning.
While the hippocampus may guide
neocortical plasticity four
by signaling success or failure.
Well, this is just what happens
when the attentional system interacts
with the orienting system.
There's also complimentary
computing in art.
In particular, the attentional
and orienting system was a complementary
as manifested
by the fact that two event related
potentials are complementary
processing negativity
and n200 processing
negativity is activated
when there's a top down
match in the attentional system.
The N200, as I just noted, is activated
when there's a mismatch
that activates the orienting system.
And you can just look across
these four rows and see that these two
kinds of ERP
potentials are manifestly complementary.
As illustrated, the complementarity
of the attention and orienting systems.
So this leads us to discuss
another paradigm introduced,
which I call complementary computing,
that has
what is the nature
of brain specializations?
Complementary computing introduces
new principles
of uncertainty and complementarity
that clarify why there are multiple
parallel processing streams with multiple
processing stages in our brains.
And a beautiful example of that
is this famous image
of the macro circuit of the visual system
from David Ranson
and his colleagues,
where you can see these multiple
parallel processing streams
and the multiple stages
needed to achieve,
I call hierarchical resolution
of uncertainty.
So what our complement complementary
properties, their analogies
like a key fits into a lock
for puzzle pieces
fitting together in words
computing one set of properties
that a stage prevents
that stage from computing
a complementary set of properties.
These complementary parallel processing
streams a balance against one another.
It's a very yin yang kind of situation,
and interactions between the streams
overcome their complementary weaknesses.
In fact, there are many
complementary processes that are known
in the brain that have been modeled.
Here is just a of them.
There are many more.
So this is a basic principle
of brain organization.
So in summary,
so far back propagation and deep learning
do not have thought to memory activation
patterns,
including critical feature patterns,
so they can't pay attention.
Indeed, they don't have any fast
information processing,
nor do they have long term memory
at the moment.
Expectation
So they can carry out hypothesis testing
using interaction
short term and long term memory traces.
Indeed, there's no neural architecture.
There's just an algorithm
in this really great contrast with
complementary computing, which discusses
the global organization of brains.
From the very start, it was shown
how easy it is to get catastrophic
forgetting.
And Carpenter and I showed it in art
when we would shut down
the matching rule.
Then we demonstrated
you could get catastrophic forgetting
if you had just
four input vectors A, B, C, D
presented in the
order ABCD, ABCD, and so on.
If they obeyed very simple subset
relationships
and here's a computer simulation of that.
Here you don't have the matching
rule is a, b, c,
d, a, b, c, a, D and you see A
is coded by category one here by category
two here by category one.
Year two we are never settled down.
But as soon as you impose
the matching rule,
learning is complete by the second trial
and after that point
you get direct access
to the globally best matching category.
Well, let's say a little more
about vigilance.
Vigilance determines what features are
learned in the critical feature pattern.
It clarifies our brains, learn concrete
knowledge
for some tasks
and abstract knowledge for others.
So in particular, high vigilance leads
to learning of narrow,
concrete categories, like a category
that fires selectively
to a frontal view of your mother's face.
Low vigilance leads to learning of broad
and abstract categories,
like everyone has its face.
It should be emphasized that
critical feature patterns are explainable
at every level of vigilance.
It's known
from physiological experiments
by does moment again
that there's vigilance
control in the infra temple cortex,
which they showed by studying
easy versus
difficult discriminations in monkeys
and the difficult condition which you'd
assume would give you their children's.
As expected,
you had enhancement of the responses
and sharpen selectivity to the intended
stimulate.
How is vigilance computed?
Well, let's say of input vector
it in states
of vector of activities,
feature detectors
at the same time as it tries
to activate the warning system.
But it
this does so multiplied by a parameter
rho, which is a sensitivity
against gravity that vigilance.
And as these features get in state,
they try to shut off
the orienting system.
And if the excitation is less
than the inhibition,
the orienting system stays quiet.
So the system can resonate and learn.
But if
inhibition isn't strong enough,
the orienting system gets activated.
You get reset
and search for new categories.
This is a very simple computation
because you have an orienting system
that's complementary
to the attentional system.
Well, how do you change
vigilance based on predictive success?
For this, we have to go from unsupervised
to supervised start models.
So we'll have
an unsupervised art,
a model in unsupervised, or B model
linked together by a learned associate
of map as occurs in the art map.
And the key point is
you can have an input here
that can create an output there
because you have both bottom up
and top down in actions
at all of these levels.
So in this way, you can learn
many to one and one too many maps.
One example of a many to one map
is let's say you're trying to categorize
visually processed a letter
A, which comes in multiple fonts.
You'll learn various visual categories.
Are they based on visual similarity?
At the same time, you're
learning auditory categories for saying A
and then the associated napkin map
all of these visual categories
of different age to saying, Hey,
but it could have been here
that these inputs were symptoms,
test treatments in a medical database
prediction
example and you're predicting
length of stay in the hospital.
The possibilities here are endless.
And then in many applications
or let's say
you're trying
to figure out what this images
and you've learned to say that's a dog.
But today you say it's rover
and that causes a major mismatch,
which drives the search to focus
attention on the particular combination
of features in this talk
that will identify it as Rover.
That leads to learning
of a visual category of Rover
in auditory categories of the name, rover
and associated map between them.
And you can now simultaneously store
expert knowledge about that image.
Well, how do
you conjointly minimize predictive error
and maximize generalization
so that you minimize using memory
resources?
Let me read you an answer
and then show what it means in images.
Match tracking realizes in kinematics
a learning principle,
namely, given a predictive error,
vigilance increases
just enough to trigger search
and the sacrifices,
the minimum generalization
to correct the error.
So let's say you've made a prediction
that must mean that vigilance is less
than the analog
between bottom up and top down.
But let's say now you have a mismatch.
Well, that'll lead to a match
tracking signal that vigilance up
till it's just above the analog match,
just big enough to drive the search.
So you've given up the minimum amount of
general deception to correct the error?
Well, all
lot mechanisms like vigilance, control
realized in lamina
cortical insular mixture
because the answer is yes.
My Ph.D.
student Extra Saatchi
and I showed this by developing
the synchronous matching order,
a smart model
which introduce
a lot more neurophysiological
and anatomical verisimilitude
into the model, including spiking
dynamics, lamina cortical circuits,
interacting
with specific and nonspecific
galactic nuclei.
This is another example
of what I'm going to computing,
and here's a schematic of the model.
You see all the cortical layers
with identified cells,
a hierarchy of cortical regions
interacting with specific thalamic nuclei
in nonspecific thalamic nuclei,
a ton anatomical data
got functionally explained in this way
and many other data as well.
For example,
we showed if you have a good enough
match between bottom up and top down,
you're going to get fast
gamma oscillations during a tension.
There was quite a bit of data
about that already, but we also showed
if you have big enough mismatch,
you'll get slower data oscillations.
That wasn't well known,
but since that time
there have been experiment in at least
four labs
in three different parts of the brain
confirming that prediction.
Most important,
vigilance control was shown
how to be a control by mismatch mediate
the colon release so big enough mismatch
in the nonspecific thalamic nucleus
activates nucleus based cells.
The miner that releases
acetylcholine in lay off
high shields across the cortex, reducing
after hyper polarization currents
and causing vigilance to go up.
And I also showed that breakdown
in acetylcholine modulation
can help to explain
the symptoms of multiple mental disorders
so as to memory consolidation.
We know there's a dynamic phase of memory
consolidation, while
the input exemplar still drives memory
search and before direct access occurs.
But what if the orienting
systems cut out?
What if you have a lesion
in the hippocampus?
Well, then, as occurs in medial temporal
amnesia,
you get unlimited anterograde amnesia
because you can search
for new categories.
You get limited retrograde amnesia
because you could have direct access
to previously learned categories.
This is a failure of consolidation,
which is mediated by the ordinances.
So you get defective novelty reactions
because that is also mediated
by the orienting system
and memory consolidation, novelty
detection mediated by the same structures
for the same reason.
It's normal priming because
priming occurs
within the attentional system.
Learning of the first item dominates.
You can get some learning,
but you can't then search.
And there's an impaired ability
to attend to relevant
dimensions of stimuli again
because you can't search.
So now where does intra temple
cortex fit in the larger brain?
I introduced the predictive
or taught algorithm
model in order
to show how the prefrontal cortex,
among other things, learns to control
all higher order intelligence.
You can find that in a 2018 paper
on my web
page,
results were published in Open Access
and in this macro circuit,
these green areas
of prefrontal cortex control processes
like working memory, learning plans,
prediction and optimized action.
These regions in red control processes
like reinforcement
learning, motion
motivation, adaptively timed learning.
The category learning I've talked about
in I.T is just in those two regions.
All these processes
control visual perception
and there are detailed
models of all of these regions
and their interactions.
Now in each brain region, in nature
and in predictive art carries out
a different function,
contrasting really dramatically
with the whole mad genius organization
of the typical deep learning network.
So I told you just a little bit
about some aspects of cognition
and why they're explainable,
but if you put in
all the biological models of perceptual
cognition, emotion and action,
they're all explainable.
And then you can observe
how perceptual and cognitive processes
work, like excitatory
matching, match based learning
to create self stabilizing,
attentive and conscious
representations of objects and events
that embody increasing expertize
about the world.
Moreover, complementary spatial
and motor processes that I couldn't
mention at all use inhibitor
free matching and mismatch based learning
to continually update spatial
and motor representations
to compensate for bodily changes
throughout life.
Taken together, they provide a self
stabilizing, perceptual and cognitive
front end for conscious awareness
and knowledge acquisition,
which can intelligently manipulate
the more labeled spatial and motor
processes that enable changing bodies
to act effectively on a changing world.
And when you put them all together,
they provide a blueprint
for designing autonomy.
This adaptive algorithms
and mobile robots with behaviors
humans can understand and control
because they're both
explainable and reliable.
See my web page,
sites (dot) BU (dot) EDU (slash) SteveG,
for these
models.
And with that, I'd like to
thank you very much
for your attention.
[End of video]
GROSSBERG (live): Before we get started,
what I want to say so
I should say that everything I talk about
and much more is in my book
Conscious Mind, Resonant Brain
How each Brain Makes and Why.
For those who don't know, it's
self-contained and non-technical.
It's written in a conversational style
so that people will know
nothing about the mind
or the brain and enjoy reading it.
And I have friends who are a rabbi,
a minister,
a painter, a gallery owner, a lawyer,
a social worker
who've all been enjoying reading it all.
So it's a big book.
It's almost 800 double column
pages with over 600 color figures.
So everything is illustrated,
but instead of costing
hundred $50, it costs $35
for the hard copy
and only $17 for the Kindle.
Because I spent a lot of my own money
so that people who are interested
in the book and read it.
And one other comment,
if people do have questions or comments
about my lecture
or anything, they're reading the book.
My email is just Steve STV
The EU Boston University study
the EU and I'll be happy to try to apply,
so thank you.
Help some researchers and explainable
AI people like Leonardo Giovanna
and Antonio de Checco
demand that any explainable
I should at the very least meet
these four criteria to be fair,
not biased in one way or another,
to be accountable or reliable,
to be secure against malicious hacker
attacks and not to be fooled easily
and also to be transparent.
Now you explained
how adaptive resonance theory or art.
And by the way, I got to say,
I love your creative
and clever
use of acronyms for your models.
My favorite one is Sovereign Model,
self-organizing vision, expectation
recognition,
emotion, intelligent, goal
oriented navigation, if I'm correct.
Amazing.
Anyway, you explained how art can address
and overcome
the issues of accountability, security
and trends, currency of current
deep learning approaches.
But it seems that this fairness issue,
a.k.a.
the problem of algorithmic bias,
has also been a growing concern lately,
especially since it's regarded
by some researchers like Antonio
Badia
as a practically intractable problem.
So I wanted to ask, in
what ways do you think art can contribute
to the ongoing quest
for mitigating this problem?
Well, when
a fairly sent me this question,
I said, Well,
first I'd like you to send me
a definition of algorithmic bias
that will clarify what you have in mind
so that I know
what I'm trying to respond to.
And you wrote me
that you part the term from body
is both the information manifold.
And you sent me a quote from page 247
that I will quote in part
before I respond
to that background information.
So there are two main reasons
for algorithmic approach to decision
making that may result in unfair
outcomes,
either at the individual or group level.
One is that data used is biased,
and another is that the algorithm
analyzes the data in such a way
that it yields biased results.
The basic point to remember
is that algorithms are designed
to achieve a certain goal not created
naturally by evolution or accident.
Thus, most algorithms are written
to detect certain patterns of interest
for a particular objective,
not just any pattern,
to be able to pick out
some patterns and disregard
others, program is
build a model of the data
by listing expectations
about what data should be like in order
to qualify as relevant to the problem.
Well, as I'll explain below,
self-organizing learning classification
and prediction models like adaptive
resonance Theory or art overcome
all the problems.
It's a general purpose device.
But why don't I try to answer that
as part of my replies to at least
subsequent questions?
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Now, as you also mentioned
in your lecture in 1988, you pointed out
17 issues with back propagation
and one of your most famous
and highly cited papers
on nonlinear neural network.
So it's been 40, 34 years now.
Now, do you see any fundamental
Copernican change of perspective
happening and deep learning research
or we still keep
we're still adding Epicycles
upon Epicycles to our Ptolemaic model?
Well, you've
sort of anticipated
what I'm going to say,
and as I said in my lecture,
there is investigators and I mentioned on
Kirkpatrick and Vella
as well have recently attempted
to modify deep learning
to overcome some of those problems.
But as I just mentioned by lecture noted
that at least in my mind,
they're like epicycles that are added
to a kind of Ptolemaic model
of the solar system
to overcome some of its problems.
But as we all know, the Ptolemaic model
ultimately crashed
because it was both qualitatively
and quantitative wrong
and they could only be solved
by throwing out the Ptolemaic model
and replacing it
with the Copernican model
that became the basis for modern
astronomy and astrophysics.
So art overcomes
foundational, deep learning problems
that can't be solved using Epicycles,
and it's already done.
It Shortly after I introduced it in 1976,
and it can't be overemphasized.
As I noted in my lecture,
Deep learning is untrustworthy
because it's not explainable
and it's unreliable
because it can experience
catastrophic forgetting.
And that happens for a basic reason.
Deep learning, just like back prop,
which is its learning
engine, is just the sheet
for with adaptive filter.
So as you note in your question,
I described these two problems
in addition of 15 others.
In my oft cited article
that I published in 1988
and the first issue of neural network,
and I also showed that
that or that already
solved the problem of the 1976.
What I find sad
is that back propagation
and deep learning architects
like Jeff Jensen, who knows all of this
background, never mention this history
and keep talking about making deep
learning.
Explain the brain.
But it can't explain the brain cause
its foundation
is contradicted by basic psychological
and neural data.
Yes, some great deep learning community.
I like comparative
discussion and criticism,
but I don't like solipsism and science.
Great.
Thank you.
Now on slide
number 50 of your presentation,
you pointed out
that art is inconsistent with models
where top down
matches suppressive
such as Bayesian explaining away.
A similar view is evident on page
195 of conscious mind resonant brain,
to which you also adds
one of many serious problems
of the Bayesian models
is that fully suppressive
matching circuits cannot solve
the stability plasticity dilemma.
Would you care to further
elaborate elaborate on this point?
Sure.
My lecture and my book summarizes
my book.
My lecture couldn't go into a lot of it.
Some of the copious
psychological anatomical
and your physical logical evidence
expectations which obey what
I call the old matching rule
or match against bottom up
input patterns.
And as the lecture briefly noted,
the matching rule is defined
by a modulatory on center
off surround network,
and the modulatory center is excitatory.
However, acting by itself.
So it can't fully excite its target
cells.
It can prime them sensitize
or modulate them
to be ready to fire vigorously
when matched, bottom up inputs arrive,
and when there is a good enough
between the parent
input and an active up down expectation,
that's reading out a circuit
that obviously ought matching role.
That's
when you get what I noted in my lecture,
what I call a feature category resonance,
because it develops
between the matched or intended features
and the recognition category
that they activate.
And it's this resonance
that synchronizes and amplifies
the matched features
while suppressing the mismatch feature.
And that sustained
resonance is important
because it sustained long enough to drive
learning in the more slowly varying
adaptive weights of the active bottom up
filter
and learned top down expectation.
And because resonance triggers
learning that I call the theory
adaptive resonance theory
and the old matching rule avoids
catastrophic forgetting as I briefly
mentioned in the lecture,
because it suppresses
irrelevant features,
using it to off surround while it's
amplifying and focusing attention
on the critical features
that regulate both
bottom up and top down
learning as well as.
Successful predictions
because they're relevant.
They've been selected by previous
learning experiences
to which discover
this set of features that are predictive.
Also in a given situation.
And along the way,
not only does the matching rule
achieve
causality and predictions,
although as the world changes,
you have to update
your plausible explanations.
It also serves as plasticity dilemma.
In brief, purely suppressive match
and can't do any of this.
It shuts off the expected data
and so it can't focus, attention
or learn about it.
And there is fully suppressive
matching and
spatial and modal learning,
but that isn't learning
to be expert about the world.
I can explain that more
if you want to know, but
that's also in my book
and these two kinds of learning,
the excitatory match based learning
and the inhibitory
mismatch learning or computation
complementary.
It's another example
of complementary computing and
the match based learning goes on
in the ventral or what cortical stream
and the mismatch learning
goes on in the where or
dorsal cortical stream.
The what stream for perception
and categorization of prediction.
The West Stream
for the spatial representation in action.
And then you need what,
where and where, what interactions
so that you can reach for
and otherwise engage through approach.
And if you look at reach for approach
to things that you've recognized.
Thank you.
Now, following from the previous question
and considering that
the free energy principle and active
inference framework has works in
progress are related to predictive
coding and Bayesian brain hypothesis.
What is your view
on the extent of compatibility
between art and active inference?
Because despite some prima facie
similarities between the two,
do you see them as fundamentally
incompatible or irritants salable?
And how could this
how could this issue
be rigorously evaluated
and positively resolved
in terms of reconciliation or integration
of art and acting and active inference
or otherwise?
Because you seem to add some more context
here, Smith.
Smith at all in their recent paper,
an active inference approach to modeling
structure learning.
Have it stated that
although there they have not explicitly
incorporated arts in a top down
attentional and feedback mechanisms,
there are mechanisms within their active
inference based model which they believe
are quite similar to top down
and bottom up feedback exchange in art.
So there seems to be
some degree of disagreement
about the compatibility
between the two frameworks.
Well, let me try to respond
to the two parts of your question.
So I'm not going to try to
talk about Smith at all for a moment.
Let's talk about free energy.
And I like getting definitions
on the table
because it's really so frustrating
to try to remember
what something is
when someone's talking about it.
So I go to Wikipedia.
Wikipedia writes in part
that the free energy principle
asserts, quote,
"that systems minimize
the free energy function
of their internal state...
which entailed beliefs about,
hidden states in their environment.
The implicit minimization of free energy
is formally related
to variational Bayesian methods
and which originally introduced
by Karl Friston as an explanation
for embodied perception in neuroscience,
where it's also known
as active inference."
We all know he's a brilliant
and very insightful man.
The free energy principle describes
the behavior of a given system
by modeling it through a Markov blanket
that tries to minimize the difference
between their model of the world
and their sense
and associative perception.
This difference can be described
as surprise, and it's minimized
by continuous correction
of the world model of the system.
One more part of
the quote The free energy principle has
been criticized for being very difficult
to understand, even for experts.
And the mathematical consistency of a
theory may have been questioned
by recent studies.
Discussions of the principle
have also been criticized for invoking
metaphysical assumptions far removed
from a testable scientific predictions,
making the principle on falsifiable.
And in a 2018 interview,
Friston acknowledged
that the free energy
principle is not properly falsifiable.
So that's risk. So
so my main concern with the free energy
principle, just like any theory
about how brain makes a mind, is
how much data can it explain
in a principle and unifying way?
That's what we do in science.
We develop theories to imperfect data.
And in the case of the free energy
principle, from what I can see
here, there is essentially no data.
And you can correct me if I'm wrong.
It therefore cannot be
evaluated as a physical theory at all.
And there's a basic for this problem.
Our brains are designed
to autonomously learn in real time
in response
to a changing non stationary world
that's filled with unexpected
events like today,
we're experiencing an unexpected event
that I didn't know till
that I'd be enjoying your company today.
Optimization principles
were designed to cope
with stationary dynamics.
One's rules and probabilities
do not change through time,
so it's not possible to, quote, minimize
the difference between
their model of the world and their sense
in associate perception, unquote,
because there is no predefined
model of the world,
which is always changing
in unexpected ways.
So you need a theory about how the world
changes.
Surprise occurs in art
when there's a big enough mismatch
between an input pad
and the currently active
top down expectation of a category
that it's activating.
This mismatch activates
the orienting system
that I briefly discussed in my book,
which interacts
with the attentional system
where the category learning does occur.
And as I illustrated in our discussions
of search in this,
you learned that it drives
hypothesis testing or memory search
to discover a better match
or to begin to learn new category.
So order discuss a better match.
In the case where
the system was
attending, some other familiar features
when the new event that occurs
but the features are new when put have
previously been categorized.
That's why they're familiar.
And then the orienting system
very quickly shifts attention
to the matching category.
And you resonate on you recognize it
consciously, often, or it begins to learn
a new category when the input represents
a truly unfamiliar
and novel situation
so as to Bayesian methods in
Hey, I'm a mathematician,
how can I not love it's right.
But the beauty of Bayes
is its simplicity.
You're just right.
The probability of two events
A and B in two different ways.
The probability of being given
eight times the probability then
the probability of a given p times
the probability of B
set them equal because they're identical.
Divide by, let's say, probability A
and then optimized.
That's Bayes
and it's a useful
statistical method and should continue
to be used in statistics.
But it's just the form of identity
where in lies its power.
It says nothing
about any physical reality,
whether in physics, chemistry or biology.
Today's rule itself
tells us nothing about physical reality
and contains no risk takes to discover
anything about physical reality
that you need to develop models driven
by a profound
analysis of large databases.
So it turns out that biological models
like R
do not incorporate the base rule.
However, authors routinely
choose the best or optimal categories
that represent the data best,
so you don't need Bayes to achieve
optimality.
Also, Bayes works best
in a stationary world with stationary
probabilities and it's designed to
learn about a non stationary
one discusses till the cows come home.
It's good for what it was designed for
and some of the neuroscientists
who try to apply Bayes
wonderful experimentalists,
but they know no math and no theory.
And you know, it's
the temptation of a free lunch.
There it is waiting to be applied.
There is no free lunch in science.
Thank you.
Now, as a final point of comparison,
what are the is Smith?
I didn't replied.
Yes, yes. Oh, okay.
You quoted a sentence of Smith.
But before that said Smith wrote,
It is also worth highlighting that as our
is intended
primarily as a proof of concept
and a demonstration of an available model
expansion reduction approach
that can be used
within active inference research.
It does not explicitly incorporate
some aspects such as top down intention
that are of clear importance
to the cognitive learning processes
and that have been implement
in previous models.
For example, the adaptive resonance.
The Iraq model of Grossberg
was designed to incorporate
top down attentional mechanisms
and feedback mechanism
to address a fundamental knowledge
acquisition problem,
the temporal instability of previously
learned information that can occur
when a system also remains
sufficiently plastic
to learn new
and potentially overlapping information.
Well, our
simulations do not explicitly incorporate
these additional complexities.
There are clear analogs.
The top down and bottom up feedback
exchanges are not within our model,
such as the prediction
and prediction error signaling
within the neural process theory
associated with active instrumental
order addresses
the temporal instable problem, primarily
the mechanism that top down expectancies
that guide attention
and match them on platform up
into patterns, which is quite similar
to the prior expectations and likelihood
mappings used with an active inference.
But as I've already noted, the quote
prior expectations
and likelihood matching mappings
within adaptive inference, quote unquote
do not have any of the key
learning, attention and memory stability
properties.
The matching New York matching
rule is a unique solution to that problem
in its variations,
it's been supported by psychological,
anatomical,
physiological and biophysical data.
It also occurs in many species.
Nobu Suruga,
for example, shows it occurs in bats.
It occurs in ferrets, you know.
So also, I think it's important to note
that when learning begins
in an art model, it doesn't need
for higher expectations or likelihood.
In fact, typically the initial bottom up,
it shows it to be random
if you don't know
what you're going to be experiencing.
And the initial top down
expectations are chosen to be large
so that whatever category
happens to be learned when it reads out
its top down expectation,
it can match whatever features
activated that category.
So they will start lodging
than their room to match
the critical features that happen
to be learned in that category.
So there are no built in models
or discovers its own models.
I should also emphasize that
active inference is also not explainable.
Sports is explainable
because a currently active
feature activity pattern,
namely the features
to which attention is paid, controls
all learning and prediction.
The model and in principle
can be measured
by neurophysiological experiments,
a model without stellar activities
or short term memory traces
that can represent the critical feature
and can't be explainable.
So I think there are quality differences.
I don't say people shouldn't
use active inference.
It may be incredibly useful and powerful
in technological applications,
but when one is doing, you know,
brain science, psychology,
it just doesn't match
the foundational data.
It's just doesn't
want a personal thing.
Thanks.
And I guess you
somehow already answered
part of this question, but
what are the possible ways in which art's
approach to explainable AI,
which,
if I'm not mistaken, can be described
as a modern dependent,
intrinsically explainable approach,
can inform active inference
inferences approach
across fertilize,
but that which is based on
objective reasoning through
constructing generative models.
For example,
as I sketched out in an pezzullo's
understanding
explanation and active inference paper.
Well, first,
I don't think or is model dependent.
As I just noted, one begins typically
to learn in art with random
initial bottom up waves
and uniformly distribute
you did top down initial adaptive way
so you can match any category
that you happen to learn.
But the authors you quoted write in part
that active inference in here,
I want to quote them
so we can find
a more detail.
Active inference
quote implies a deep generative model
that includes a model of the world
used to infer policy
in a higher level model
that attempts to predict which policies
will be selected
based upon a space of hyper
that is counterfactual explanations
and which can subsequently
be used to provide retrospective
explanations about the policies pursued.
So again,
artworks
without a generative model of the world
or any predefined paths, the course
one is trying to discover
what changing world it happens to be,
and then nobody knows what it is
at priority
and in general or not.
Classify responds to a front end
of three processes
that process perceptual data
from one or another sense, notably
vision and audition,
where we get most of our information
about the world.
And that's why a classifier
like art begins its work in the brain,
in the temporal cortex,
where it receives highly
pre processed perceptual representation.
So for decades,
the work went into understanding.
Brains consciously stay in here
and in the case of vision or
classifies perceptual boundaries
and surfaces that require
multiple stages of processing.
Because as I mentioned
briefly,
they were the outcome of what I call
hierarchical resolution of uncertainty.
You need multiple stages
to define a perceptual boundary surface
one reason being because the sensory
organs registers such noisy
and incomplete data like you may know,
there are photosensitive
has a huge blind spot
where you can't register any sense,
any virtual signal.
The blind as big as the phobia
or all of our high resolution
vision occurs.
So it's not a little thing.
And moreover, veins
come out of the 12 year and occlude
the retina in multiple places.
And you can register visual signals
on the veins, either
So the signal you're getting
is very incomplete and it takes multiple
processing stages
to overcome those uncertainties.
And my cousin, I've worked for decades
to explain
how that happens
and maybe I'll stop after
so much.
Now, this next question
is of a personal interest to me,
because currently working on modeling
some probabilistic aspects
of affective response to music
and your most recent paper toward
understanding the brain dynamics of music
immensely helped
me gain
a better understanding of entrainment.
As you pointed out in the supplementary
notes for this paper,
violation of prior learned
expectations is instrumental
in inducing a wide range
of affective responses
in musical and nonmusical situations.
Some psychologists, such as Patrick
Houston, have distinguished
between perception
and arousal of emotions.
Trust you, but you left out a question.
This is lots of time where you just skip
the next question.
I want up quite a bit about it
so how do you see the future
of art and neuro inspired?
I think that will be our last question.
Okay. So come back to that.
Yes, yes. Thank you.
Because that
that's an important question. Yes.
Okay.
So sorry to interrupt.
I just want to be sure no problem.
Thank you. Now, yes.
Well, some psychologists
such as Patrick Forslund,
have distinguish between the perception
and the arousal of emotions
in the context of musical experience.
And also several studies
such as The Works of Use, Lynn
and Gabrielson from the Psychology
Department of Sully University
have shown that despite music's ability
to communicate
a wide range of positively
and negatively emotions,
it is somehow
evokes mostly positively balanced
emotions.
For instance, we can easily perceive rage
or anger in music
without necessarily getting angry.
On the other hand,
we're more likely to actually feel
elevated and happy
after listening to music.
And also the evidence shows
that this disparity between perception
and evocation of emotion
is probably even more significant
in musical experiences
than any other nonmusical experiences.
So how can this difference in diversity
between perceived and aroused, aroused
or evoked musical emotions
be accounted to be accounted
for within art framework?
Can it possibly be regarded
as another kind of broken symmetry,
as you mention on page 621 of your book,
but specific to musical?
So as you've noted,
I haven't studied
this issues in the context of music, but
I'll try to venture some general comments
I should note that the lab and art model,
which is
a development of art, to show
how and why all neocortical circuits
that support perception and cognition
typically share a canonical
six layer circuit.
My colleagues and I have modeled,
just as in our brains, variations
of this canonical
lamina circuit can support all perceptual
and cognitive processes.
So there's a major generalization of art,
and we've done it for vision, speech
and cognitive working memory
and planning in particular.
So the main point
is that the alignment of circuitry
is basically in all perceptual
areas, vision or
that's how one can create
a context for discussing music.
And in fact, my work on music
applied such discoveries.
I was able to put together
discoveries that had been made
based on
what I believe were different
evolutionary pressures that had
the organization about brains.
But that evolution also discovered
and I try to sketch how
if you put some them together
in a certain way,
then the capacity for
learning
and consciously music could arise.
So now how about arousal?
So it's essential, of course,
to all awareness and consciousness.
Your cortex needs to be adequately
aroused for waking
consciousness to occur at all.
It also arousal plays a major role
in the processing of emotions
and is very relevant.
The musical issues
was mitigated dipole model explains
how own and plus this piece of this
that's organized
in all parts of our brain
perceptual cognitive motor
affective in particular,
emotions are organized in pairs
as in such an emotional dipole.
And one reason is because
emotions need to compete
with each other,
such as fear versus relief.
For example, in
post-traumatic stress disorder therapy,
a therapist may try to help patients
to think about positive experiences
that generate relief
in order to inhibit the chronic
that's so destabilizing during PTSD.
So their opposites are competing
and. Another property
that arousal enables
is that this sudden offset of an emotion
like here,
let's say during escape behavior,
let's say,
you know, favorite example of mine is,
you know, some cruel experimentalist
puts the picture in a box
that was electrified.
The pitch is feeling pain and fear.
It's dashing frantically around,
trying to keep its feet off the floor.
It bangs into a red buzzer,
the buzzer shuts the shock off
and the animal experienced
a wave of relief or positive motivation
for learning the escape response.
So this rebound from theater relief
that can
be associated with actions
that lead to escape and can motivate
escape by means in the future
is energized by arousal.
Indicate a dipole.
You shut off the external cue of shock,
but the arousal is technically
or has sustained activity
in both this gear and the channel.
So because the arousal is sustained
or tonic through time
and equally activates
the fear and relief channels
when fear suddenly decreases,
then arousal and the relief
channel wins, the competition.
And therefore I call what I call
an antagonistic rebound
from fear relief
that activates the relief channel
and thereby
providing motivation for escape,
whether reactive or learned
to escape experiences.
And I want to appropriate,
which is related to some degree
the music that the non occurrence
of an expected event
and by itself cause
a burst of arousal
and that's an antagonistic rebound
and can slap emotions
from the negative in so doing.
And I always love that discovery
because I especially loved discoveries
where the occurrence of nothing
has profound effects on future behavior.
So it's the non occurrence,
the expectation because of this mismatch
that can emotions
now how this influences
the perception of music needs more work.
It's as I mentioned my paper
I haven't tried to study the
I my my paper on music
I feel is like
you know a drop in the bucket.
And hopefully if I don't get around to it
someone else will.
But the above examples show
that arousal and emotion
are not the same thing
because arousal can support all emotion,
peer relief, hunger, satiety, whatever
the ones that when the competition
or then able
to support
compatible behaviors by motivating them.
And I've
also explained that the level of arousal
must be chosen
within an intermediate range
to support normal behaviors.
It's the kind of golden mean.
There's an inverted you
on the effects of having arousal
from too little or too much.
And if you have too little arousal,
you have an under arouse syndrome
which can support symptoms like autism.
And although arousal can support
symptoms of abuse like schizophrenia,
there's only one of many factors
in these diseases.
But I'm happy to say that subsequent
clinical data supported those predictions
that these two mental disorders
are the opposite speeds
of the arousal in gratitude.
So I think and you know,
this is very speculative because
I've never really seriously studied it.
And I try not to speculate, but
the kind
of arousal that
music activates are generally positive,
just like the arousal that activates
exploratory behaviors is positive,
is somehow linked
to a a sonic adventure, if you like.
There's no aversive cue
when listening to music,
except perhaps music played
so loud as to cause
a headache or your damage
or even a seizure.
In susceptible individuals, though
there's no particular reason
why it shouldn't be positive.
So now which question you want to ask me?
I think we're left
with just two other questions.
If you're not too tired to start with.
As a final point, a person noticed
that on a more philosophical.
Yes, the last where
until last the two questions.
So you want to uh
how do you see the future of our neurons
but our research.
And before that. Yes, before that
I just wanted to
ask you about the your view
about artificial consciousness.
Do you see.
I really need the first answer.
The answer the second question.
Okay. As you wish. Yes.
Okay.
So so. Yeah.
And how do you see.
Yeah, yes, it's quite fine.
And how do you see the future of art
and brain inspired A.I.
research in general in view,
what research areas
ought to gain more attention
than they do today?
So I'll give you quite a general answer,
but it implies
what I think about this.
So first, with a caveat, I like to say
I couldn't predict the present,
so I can't predict the future.
That being said, I believe that
all engineering technology
and I will increasingly embody
autonomous adaptive intelligence
in the coming century,
and we can already see its beginnings
in autonomous automobiles and
and increasingly autonomous controllers
on the factory floor.
And many people have written about it.
And I think art
will play a central role in this,
as well as other models
that are summarized in my book.
And that's because already in 1980,
I published a thought experiment
in the journal Psychological Review,
which was then
and still probably remains
the leading theory journal in psychology.
And you may recall that Einstein derived
both special relativity theory
and general relativity
from Ford experiments.
And let me just clarify
that my thought experiment,
when they describe their enormous power.
So my thought experiment was about how
any system an autonomous fleet
what about autonomous
correct
predictive errors in a changing world
and the hypotheses upon
which what experiment were derived.
But just a few facts that are familiar
to us all from daily life.
And they are familiar
because represent ubiquitous
environmental pressures on the evolution
of our brains over the millennia.
And when they act together,
I think just art is the unique outcome.
That's a huge claim and I turn to
the power of the thought experiment.
Not any personal ego trip without belief
in particular, nowhere in the thought
experiment of the word
mind or brain mentioned.
So if you accept that these facts
about the world exist, which we all do,
and that they're always operating on us,
then you have to accept the outcome.
If you believe in the scientific
method logic.
So what is a universal solution
to the problem of economists?
Error correction a change in world
turn another way
If you can find a mistake in the thought
experiment, then I think you either
have to believe in art,
like dynamics may be expressed
in life, in art
or your favorite art variant.
Or you have to give up your belief
in logic and the scientific method.
It doesn't imply that I can't be further
developed.
I expect a large number of scientists
to acknowledge and technologies
to be busy developing,
much like architecture's long instrument.
So maybe now we
can go to your philosophical note
with that.
Yes. Thank you so much.
Now, just as I mentioned,
I mentioned earlier,
I just wanted to ask about your view
about your view
on artificial consciousness.
Do you see the consciousness
as artificially reducible
or engineer able as some researchers
like Mike Soames leads?
Is there a fundamental distinction
between biologically conscious agent
and an artificial agent
with a fully simulated
computational model of consciousness?
I know it's a big, big question,
but I couldn't resist asking your opinion
as an authority on consciousness
modeling.
I'm happy to give it a shot.
So as I just noted, my work on art
suggests itself the universal
about how we can learn
to correct
predictive errors in a changing world.
My work also shows and
analysis of hierarchical resolution
of uncertainty.
Remember,
like how you go from sun, a noisy retina
to the surface representation
that can control looking in reaching
how evolution may have been driven
to discover
conscious states.
So this was a surprise to me too.
Conscious states were needed in order
to choose
that processing level.
The levels that computes the sufficiently
complete context sensitive and stable
representation in the case of vision,
the surface representation
with which to successfully plan
and act to value calls.
So let me make it clear.
So you start with a noisy rat
and you have to go up all of these stages
until you get sufficiently complete
surface and boundary representation
that you can use
to regulate successful action.
And if you used one of the stages,
it would lead to incorrect actions
which would kill you off
by Darwinian selection.
So how the hell do you know
where the stage is, where you can compute
this sufficiently complete,
extensive and stable one
and I
proposed in vision, I predicted
that the choice is embodied
in what I call surface
shroud resonance between destroyed
visual cortical area, the floor
and the next processing stage.
A stirrup while cortex of the state.
So it's in the poor.
You get this really good surface
representation
and then a resident
between the surface and spatial attention
which fits the surface,
that spatial attention and PPC
is called a shroud of the pilot
gave it that name.
A surface shroud resonance
allows you to a conscious
spatial attention to the surface
that you're going to use the controller
looking and reaching behaviors.
So it's a way of ensuring
you have a good enough representation
to control action.
So the shroud is
computed in plastic parietal cortex,
which is part of the dorsal
or where cortical stream
and the
shroud modulates invariant category
learning in the ventral
or what cortical stream?
I can't go into that now,
but my book discusses it.
The category of learning itself
in the what cortical, as I indicated,
is supported
by a feature category resonance.
And so the surface shroud resonance
is modulating invariant category learning
in the featured category resonance
with surface
shroud resonance also supports in
the future category
resonance is supporting
conscious recognition
and when they synchronize across streams
on a familiar object,
that's when you consciously see
something that you know about.
Okay, so
conscious states here
arise due to learning requirements.
This sort of fell out of the wash of
how you do invariant category learning
and learning in particular
catastrophic forgetting.
It's regulating
feature category resonance.
So given
that the above solutions
the computational universe so
in the sense I sketch
the self-organizing machine
that embodies them
should be able to support
internal representations
with parametric properties
mimic the state.
So whether such a machine
can experience conscious qualia
remains as much of a mystery
to machines as it does for humans.
And that's
because no computational theory,
which after all, is
just a set of equations,
can't do more than imitate
the dynamics of our brains.
Perhaps with great precision.
I don't have a clue why
the representations that
I've worked so hard to explain
huge amounts of psychophysical data
about them
excruciating 3D form.
Just go through the list
why they support Qualia.
I don't know.
Ask God,
or whatever God you choose to believe in
in the 21st century.
Thank you so much, Professor.
I think we have a couple of questions
in the chat
but we are actually approaching
our two hour limit.
I don't know, Daniel, if
it's a good place to stop or
whatever you say.
I think that's great place to stop.
You've given us a lot to
to think about and digest.
And I hope that these words are taken
well and paid attention to might create
some categories,
activate some categories.
But Professor Grossberg,
thanks again for this amazing livestream.
We really appreciate. It.
Appreciate it.
And I'm depending on younger
people like yourself to do
just what you said, Daniel!
I'm not going to be around
that much longer. So
I hope you have,
whether with my work
directly or related work,
you have a very fulfilling
intellectual adventure.
I know I've been on a wild ride
since I was 17, and
that's 65 years of discovery.
I've loved every minute of it.
Thank you very much! See you soon.
Thank you.
It was really pleasure meeting you.
Thank you. And
so you'll tell me
when I'll see this, right? - somewhere
on YouTube?